i have a review for you and some
analysis of
various bluetooth codecs
for a while some members have been
interested in adding
bluetooth support to existing systems
that don't have it
specifically some of them are looking
for doing that
in live sound and more professional
applications and i
tested a couple of adapters there and
frankly the performance was not all that
great
um so a suggestion was made to test a
bunch of other ones more consumerish
brands
and i decided to get some of those
and today's one is a product by topping
called the bc3 it's a cute little device
it's shiny and feels good and
substantial
uh a seller in china aliexpress
sent this to me hopefully i'm
pronouncing the name right is yao
yao tigger hi-fi i appreciate them
sending this to me the link is on the
review
anyway uh this adapter actually has
battery in it so you can charge it with
a
usb connection on the side and
then it works portably so you can take
it to your car and what have you
the controls are touch and so they don't
have tactile feedback even though they
look
kind of nice um one of the cool things
about this that made my testing quite
interesting and simple and maybe i'll
show you on the
screen here is the addition of
optical output digital output um so we
can actually test the performance of
various uh
bluetooth codecs without worrying about
the digital analog converter
on these devices but i also tested that
and this device not only has line output
but also has headphone output
the digital uh toslink output is a combo
jack
and so you get line out analog and you
get digital
optical there's a little adapter in
there that converts that
3.5 millimeter connector to regular
larger
toslink uh optical cable so
um aptx is the original uh
original it's one of the most common uh
codecs in
in bluetooth and uh
every time i test it i see this uh
really bad
spectrum analysis here i'm just feeding
the uh
the device at one kilohertz tone so an
ideal system would show this one's
peak over here with noise floor down to
nothing
this is actually this again is a digital
analysis so there should be no
analog noise so the noise floor should
just fall off the bottom
um but it does not then it's you know
pretty far
up here and then it just truncates
heavily and adds these other spikes so
uh this is a very simple signal one
killer's tone
any dumb compression algorithm should be
able to handle this with ease it's not
complex not noise and other things but
clearly it's not and you can see the
waveform on this left it couldn't be
simpler
than you know any other music that that
you might play
um the measured sign ad is
only 67 db which is quite poor again
this is a perfect digital output out of
this device so
if we had a lossless transmission the
sign out would be through the roof
switching to aec we see the same problem
i've seen with other devices oh i should
mention that the source of
the signal is my samsung s89
s8 plus if you turn on the developer
options
and go in there you can actually select
the uh different codecs in there
uh i'll get to ldac there's actually two
things you got to do to turn on ldac but
it's nice you can go in there and select
whichever one you want and you can even
select it while
something's playing and it'll
dynamically switch which is
kind of cool but uh you're basically uh
at the mercy of the encoder that's in
there you the
everything that's the uh the phone is
producing is actually uncompressed
and a real-time encoder is compressing
it into these formats dynamically
and whatever aac encoder is in there is
pretty horrible
i don't know if it comes from samsung or
it comes from google
but it produces this really poor
response ac is an advanced audio codec
it beats mp3 easily uh at the day rates
that bluetooth provides it should be
walking apart for it to generate a pure
one killer's tone
not only does it not do that it
generates these sidebands and then
generates all this garbage on the right
and i've seen this before with from
other devices so
um i'm assuming it's a common
problem to the encoder on android i
apologize for not having an iphone with
a
c in there some i planned on doing for
this review but i forgot so
that'll come in the future um but for
now if you have an android device
this is what you're gonna get which is
pretty bad um
because it's overall noise and
distortion are lower though the sign
that improves but
remember that sign ad is is a hardware
measurement
indeed we're you know at some level we
are testing hardware when i get to
analog but for now
it's not the best metric when it comes
to fidelity and
actually it's not a good metric at all
when it comes to lossy codex
but as a test of a hygiene uh
it's not bad to see what it did to a
simple
tone spc was the original music codec
that was added to
bluetooth and
it's uh we can see that it's noise floor
is high so it actually gets a worse cyan
add rating
than aac because of that but it's
actually pretty clean you see
the one killer's tone and yes you see
some sidebands here and some spikes here
but to me this is a cleaner spectrum
than what we got with
ac up here indeed i've done listening
tests with the last device that i tested
and i thought the ac
sounded worse than spc um
in this case i think sbc is using much
higher data rate than aac
and because of that even though it's not
as sophisticated
of it the kodak is able to produce
better sound quality
on that now something new and is this
ldac codec
i've always seen the developer option to
turn on ldac in my
android phone but every time i turned it
on it would turn right back off
then i realized there's actually a
second option under bluetooth when you
turn on the bluetooth and the bluetooth
options
for some reason the ldac on off is also
there so you have to enable it in both
places
number one number two it defaults to
16-bit mode so if you turn it on
use it that way and play the bits
you get an extremely good sign add
relative to the other ones 97 db which
is the limit of what you can get with 16
bit format
um you get all these little spikes in
here usually start at one killers
100 percent go up this always tells me
that there's truncation happening
from 16 a 24 bit test signal that i'm
running
to 16-bit so we're actually screwing up
the bits before we hand it off to the to
the device
i can remedy that by going developer
options and turning on 24-bit mode
which doesn't do anything for the other
codecs by the way but on ldac as soon as
i do that look at what happens now
look at how clean the spectrum is and
sign out of 113 db almost um
which is phenomenal i mean this is
extremely good relative to the
you know look at the garbage we've been
dealing with here and here and
here so it's a it finally does what
ldac at 24 bit it does what it should be
doing
i did a test for distance
the mode there are different modes where
you can set it to adaptive mode where
it'll switch up and down in bitrate
depending on on
quality of the rf signal i left it in
the default which is adaptive
and i assume as i increase the distance
it would switch down to lower rates and
distort
um maybe it switched down but i didn't
notice it i went as far as uh 23
25 feet and this performance that you
see was maintained so very good uh you
know that was nice i thought maybe just
one or two meters that you get this kind
of performance
but that was not the case so
now this is the digital output out of
the uh the uh
this little box uh the bc3 uh how can
you get this this kind of
analog performance we're not going to
listen to toslink so i hooked it up to a
topping
d30 pro dac uh tossling out of this
device
and then tossling into that and then i
use the balanced output
out of that and uh
we basically see the same performance
113 db so
end to end over an rf connection uh
sending a one kilo is pure tone simple
tone we're able to achieve
state-of-the-art up to 20-30 feet
over bluetooth which is uh remarkable i
mean this is
threshold of hearing stuff uh real music
will be more complex and
and that requires testing with listening
tests you can these kind of simple tests
are not good
but as a baseline level we see that
there's only one codec
in bluetooth one driven by a
android at least that gives us the
transparency we're looking for
the other ones i have listened to them
like i said all of
them uh generate artifacts to my ears
with spc being the cleanest but still
not nearly cd quality
i have not done listening tests yet with
ldac i'll do that but
based on what i'm seeing in here is it's
just
numerically it's extremely clean
now this little box also has its own
analog output it's on
dac inside and i measured that and i
measured with the best stack that we
have which is this ldac
and we see that performance about 92 93
db synapse
which is essentially just a hair below
cd quality
so even the internal dac in this
is good enough that if you just want to
listen to city quality music
uh 16 bit yeah 44 killers
is essentially good enough for that
and we can see that in dynamic ranges is
16 bits also
ideally you'd have the channel be much
cleaner than the content you play but
you know waving my hands over it
it's it's good enough it has headphone
output
it's the same performance is lying out
but probably has better drive capability
the output level is 2 volts
2 volts is very good means it'll drive
even high impedance
headphones to reasonable volume uh
on this thing so uh post the review that
i published this was
came out yesterday people asked for uh
frequency response test
and i thought it was a good suggestion
so you're the first ones to see the
frequency response test i just added
them to the review
um i'm only showing you two of them at a
time because all four of them on top of
each other was hard to read
so first i ran an ldac sweep um from uh
and it was basically by the way ignore
this little wiggliness the
special kind of test that that i use to
run these kind of measurements
generates a little bit of oscillation
there that's okay um
but basically it's from 20 hairs to 20
kilohertz it's this pink line hopefully
you can see
uh is ldac and it's basically ruler flat
to 20 kilos which is the
measurement limit of this test spc
codec it does very well flat but then
all of a sudden at 14.5 kilohertz it
starts to
roll off so there's some kind of
filtering in there but and by 20
kilohertz
you're down 5 db so you know how good
are your ears how young you are
whether you hear this or not but it's a
little unfortunate
this is a very common technique to get
efficiency in lossy codex because the
high frequencies were all the noises
noise is random it doesn't have
commonality with previous samples which
means it is harder to compress
it has higher entropy as we call it so
if you just get rid of a little bit of
the high frequencies it helps
compression efficiency tremendously so
and that's what they do at the chop off
basically twenty percent twenty five
percent of the uh
i don't know what that is for 15 of the
bandwidth
but gives you much better quality for
what's left in it if it didn't filter
that then
the you know the mid bands would suffer
a lot more and that's where your hearing
is more sensitive and all of us hear
that so
uh you know it's it's a reasonable
trade-off although since the competition
ldag is able to do a flat response
questions you know why couldn't sbc do
the same thing
um the uh hopefully you can see ac in
here is this green curve
it's very similar to the spc one up here
i was surprised that it also filters
starting at 15 kilohertz
uh i don't know what data rate um
the encoder is using in in
android again it's a real-time asc
encoder
how good his algorithm is uh it's
anything at 128 kilobits per second and
higher with ac
should provide response all the way up
to 20 killers
why it's starting to roll off at 15
kilohertz
maybe it's at lower bit rate uh maybe
again they
put a filter in there to make it easier
to encode i don't know
but you know it's bad uh you know
clearly somebody didn't do this kind of
objective analysis and caught these
kinds of design mistakes
aptx i don't know what it's doing it's
it's just generating noisy output
starting at five kilohertz
and uh really confuses this test by the
time you get to 20 kilos so
it really tries to chop off all the high
frequencies to benefit the
low frequencies this test by the way
is a chirp sweep which means it goes
from
low frequencies to high frequency
dynamic tests
so when i run the dashboard it's a one
kilohertz it keeps repeating
whereas this test is actually dynamic so
codecs that rely on windowing
and and look at previous and next
samples uh they tend
to see this as a more difficult test
than the pure tones
um then this kind of testing we usually
use for headphone testing and
speaker testing where we run this sweep
once and it's
chirps like a bird chirping and then we
get a bunch of data out of it
and one of the things that it spits out
for free beyond frequency response is
distortion plus noise for
most of the frequency range that we're
interested in in this case 10 kilohertz
we see that the ldac at the bottom is
absolutely cleanest
it's not even a competition between
heldac and the other ones it's just it's
you know distortion drops below of minus
120 db
below 500 hertz so extremely clean above
this i was surprised that
these three codecs depending on
frequency they did something different
aptx just butchers the highs as we
already know and and some of the
mid-bands
but because it butchers all that it
tends to produce very good response
uh in all of here uh and
then the other ones at lower frequencies
so to the extent you know you cared
about bass and
and up to one kilohertz uh maybe voices
and things like that
is actually better than the other two
codecs uh svc is sort of in the middle
it starts off decently and then he gets
really chewed up in here not sure what
the heck is doing
it's got very you know frequency
dependent uh artifacts
uh on this thing and then ac
is uh weird and that it's the worst in
low frequencies then it does better
at higher frequencies so but you know i
don't know that this kind of analysis is
all that useful other than just a large
distinction between
these three codecs and then the you know
ldac which stands on its own
um once again i want to repeat that this
is a simple
test tones we don't usually test
perceptual codecs with
measurements like this but we take for
granted that they can all
produce flat frequency response and that
you know pure tones don't bother them
the fact that pure tones bother these
three
means the implementation is broken
design is broken something is really bad
there
um a bit about ldac um
it's a newer codec it's not available on
every device it was invented by sony
and sony gives away the source code to
ldac is part of the
android open source but uh
that doesn't mean it's free you have to
go negotiate a license with them and
it's funny they actually tell you to
tell you it takes several months
to negotiate a license uh you know
that's usually between two big companies
arguing over a bunch of different gnarly
things and i explained some of the
issues you could run into uh when you
try to license these agreements
essentially the company that licenses
this kodak to you wants to make sure you
never sue them and that
you can never sue anybody else that
license that either
if you're a patent holder yourself you
don't want to agree to those just
because your licensing code like you
don't want to have
all your other ip rights taken away so
you go through this
you know mating dance that can take
forever and sometimes impossible to
reconcile even the non-disclosure can be
a major sticking point to uh tucson but
once you've done all that then you gotta
cough up money
um royalties on a per device basis uh
on that up here i was surprised and
unpleasantly surprised that topping is
an official licensee and
listed over here i don't see companies
like samsung in here for example
you know because there's the samsung and
sony are like oil and water
um maybe samsung has some license
like in some products but i'm not seeing
it here certainly you don't see apple
in here apple only wants ac i believe
aca patents have all run out so
it's free to them if they put ldac in
there that have to
uh go cough up licensing fees and and
given how many devices they sell i don't
think they're gonna
want to do that um again i'll go i'll
test aac at some point
to see if it matches or beats uh uh
this uh just as a side point i'm a
android user and i'll have a iphone 6s
that i got uh
six ac or whatever it's called just for
testing and i hate getting in it and
and do things in it because i'm not a
apple iphone user so
a bit of laziness on my part but i've
got to unlock it and and
do some testing which i will do okay so
hopefully you learned something about
the uh
the different codecs in here even if
you're not interested in this device i
actually found this project quite fun uh
these are all discoveries for me too i
hadn't measured
ldac before and it was a very pleasant
surprise to see
the performance it has so my
recommendation is
if you've got a phone make sure you can
generate ldac
and for anything that receives it see if
you can get ldac inside your dac
or whatever device you buy but if you
can't this isn't all this is only 69
dollars so
cheap enough and essentially gives you
transparent
24-bit performance on this thing so
it's pretty cool to just turn on your
phone pull up your favorite
app and stream to this thing as if it's
a
desktop class you know streaming and
you know the bluetooth at least on this
my experience with this just plug and
play instantly works
and like i said this is also battery
operated so
quite cool to get very very high
fidelity
on the go either out of its analog
output or hook it up to a
another dac with balanced output for
live sessions and
professional applications okay so i hope
you
enjoyed this video as much as i enjoyed
producing the
review and the video and see you in a
future one
bye